l'organisation mondiale du commerce
certains à une chute du commerce mondial
bien supérieure à celle causée par la
crise financière de 2008 2009
dans son scénario optimiste lohan ci
prévoit un plongeon de 13 % du commerce
international en 2020 suivie d'un rebond
de 21% en 2021
mais dans le scénario pessimiste le
commerce chuterait de 32 % en 2020 avant
de regagner 24% en 2021 la suite des
choses dépendra de la durée de la
pandémie et des mesures mises en place
pour stimuler la reprise avec nous ce
soir à washington nous recevons avec
grand plaisir
olivier blanchard du peterson institute
for international economics et ancien
chef économiste du fonds monétaire
international bonsoir monsieur blanchard
bonsoir alors l'om c'est aujourd'hui
parlent de la plus grande crise de
l'histoire pour le commerce
international
quelle est votre analyse à vous de la
situation actuelle oui non je pense
qu'ils ont raison et je pense que le
scénario pessimiste que vous avez
indiquée est ce vraiment le plus
réaliste il va là une très grosse
récession dans presque tous les pays du
monde mais là les effets sur le commerce
international va être amplifié
on voit une énorme diminution du
commerce même étant donné l'activité
l'activité est faible
donc les chiffres qu'ils ont données
paraissent raisonnables si j'avais à
choisir un jeu sexy dans un texte que
vous avez publié ce matin dans un texte
d' analyse avec le peterson institute
vous dit qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une
récession normale et qu'il vaut mieux se
tromper en donnant trop d'argent aux
gens présentement plutôt que troupes
expliquez-nous votre réflexion là dessus
oui d'abord une récession normale sont
en général une récession ou pour une
raison quelconque les consommateurs ou
les entreprises décident de dépenser
moins et donc une démission de
l'allemande et une diminution de la
production
là on est dans un scénario qui est
totalement différent où le problème
vient du côté de l'offre c'est la
fermeture des entreprises et donc comme
tout prix ce fait ne peuvent pas
produire donc c'est un choc
ce qu'on appelle un choc d'offre plus
qu'un choc de demande et c'est une
récession
on a d'un type qu'on a en fait
absolument jamais vu et dans ce contexte
ce qui se passe et que c'est extrêmement
rapide extrêmement fort et toute une
série de gens qui se retrouvent sans
travail du jour au lendemain les
entreprises qui sont obligés de fermer
soit parce qu'elles ne sont pas clients
soit parce qu'elles sont légalement
obligés de le faire et beaucoup d'entre
elles se retrouvent dans l'une comme
dans des conditions financières
excessivement difficile et dans ce
contexte la court terme il faut faire au
mieux
bien sûr on voudrait donner de l'argent
uniquement à ceux qui en ont besoin mais
c'est très difficile à faire et donc jeu
qu'on fait c'est qu'on arrose très
généreusement on donne probablement plus
que nécessaire et pour moi des gens qui
vont se voir de l'argent qui ne l'ont
pas déjà mais c'est le coût à payer pour
faire que les gens qui en ont vraiment
besoin et une bonne chance de pouvoir
survivre dans les mois qui viennent ou
les entreprises de pas me faire faillite
et donc cet argent c'est pour lutter
contre le virus et pour aider les gens
dans votre analyse vous ne semblez pas
tout à fait convaincu cependant qu'il va
falloir nécessairement stimuler
l'économie au sortir de la crise
pourquoi d'abord l'argent et pour deux
choses à aider pour se combattre le
virus donc dépenser suffisamment pour
qu'on puisse développer des tests s'est
rapidement sur une très grande échelle
ensuite protéger les gens qui se
retrouvent dans des conditions très
difficiles d entreprise très difficile
mais ensuite en général dans une
récession normale ce qu'on essaie de
faire c'est d'augmenter la demande de
manière à retourner à peu près où on
était avant la récession
mais là ce qui se passe c'est qu'il
était absolument hors de question de
pouvoir retourner à là où on est égale
pour le moment en tout cas de pouvoir
retourner à là où on était à trois mois
les entreprises sont fermées donc si on
a augmenté la demande sans se poser de
question on a augmenté beaucoup ce qui
se passerait c'est qu'il y aurait trop
de demande pour les biens qui peuvent
être reproduits donc du point de vue de
l'utilisation de la demande il faut être
assez prudent il faut donner aux gens ce
dont ils ont besoin tous vivent dans nos
entreprises ce qu'ils ont besoin pour
survivre mais donner plus d'argent ou
jean augmenterait la demande peut être
au delà de 2 2 ce qui est possible de
produire à ce stade on s'est beaucoup
inquiété
de la hausse des dettes publiques après
la crise financière de 2008 vous étiez
au fmi à l'époque et vous aviez exprimé
cette inquiétude en proposant toute une
feuille de route pour réduire
l'endettement public
aujourd'hui comment on doit réagir face
aux dettes des gouvernements qui vont
sérieusement s'alourdir bon je vais un
peu corriger votre votre appétence
interprétation de l'histoire que j'étais
moins inquiet que beaucoup de gens de
l'augmentation de la dette et je pensais
que ce n'était pas nécessairement une
bonne idée de la réduire rapidement
après la partie intensif de la crise est
là je fais la même analyse je pense que
les dettes dont certainement beaucoup
augmenté mais on a la chance entre
guillemets d'avoir des taux d'intérêt
qui sont très très rares ce qui fait que
le coût de la dette est très très bas et
je pense en conséquence que d'une part
on doit dépenser ce qui est nécessaire
maintenant sans se poser trop de
questions et que quand la dette sera
augmentée et elle aura aucune honte et
on pourra vraiment dû faire face sans
avoir à prendre des milieux dramatique
sans avoir à augmenter les impôts de
manière considérable ou diminuer les
dépenses
donc je crois c'est très important de
faire ce qu'il faut maintenant
d'accepter l'augmentation de la date et
on a priori on devrait s'en sortir même
avec des niveaux dette beaucoup plus
élevés que ceux d'aujourd'hui et on ne
sera pas obligé donc d'aller vers des
mesures quand qualifié d' austérité
à l'époque je crois que bien sûr il est
désirable autres choses égales de
diminuer la dette
bien sûr mais il faut le faire sans
conséquences économiques graves et tant
que la politique monétaire ne peut pas
aider pour moi la politique monétaire ne
peut pas vraiment aidé à à l'activité
des ddv taux sont à peu près à 0 il faut
être très très prudent sur ce qu'on a
appelé une austérité budgétaire elle
saura le faire à un amant mais pas tout
de suite qu'on ne m'ont pas dans les
quelques années qui viennent est ce que
vous êtes d'avis dans la crise actuelle
que la coordination justement de la
politique monétaire la politique fiscale
donc entre les gouvernements et les
banques centrales est suffisante et bien
équilibré bien approprié
on peut toujours espérer plus mais pour
le moment je vois rien de dramatique
entre il me semble que ce que font les
gouvernements se dépenser ce qui est
nécessaire de dépenser et les banques
centrales font
sorte que les taux d'intérêt restent bas
ce qui est assez justifiée donc pour le
moment il me semble que ça marche à peu
près entre les pays il n'ya pas beaucoup
coordination mais là encore elle n'est
pas essentiel ce qui est essentiel c'est
que chaque pays dépense ski nécessaires
pour faire face à la crise et que les
banques centrales dans chaque pays fasse
qu'il faut la seule dimension dans
laquelle je vais avoir beaucoup plus de
coordination et de générosité
c'est là d'où pays émergents l'aide aux
pays pauvres qu'ils vont souffrir
énormément et n'ont absolument pas les
moyens de faire face à la crise tout
seul
est-ce qu'il faut repenser dans l'avenir
la place de l'état ici on apparaît
beaucoup de subventions salariales ou
soit de nationalisation d'activité de
revenu minimum universel garantie est ce
qu'il va falloir réfléchir à ça la place
de l'état dans l'économie d'un soutien
aux gens dont il est clair que ce qu'on
a compris comment ça qu'ici que les
mourants de l'état est très très
important dans une crise de gens si on
essaie des marchés fonctionner sans
intervention d'état on serait dans une
situation absolument informatique est ce
que ça veut dire que quand on retourne
d'un état tout normal il faut que le
rôle de l'état soit dramatiquement
différents mon opinion pour le moment
c'est non je pense que la leçon qu'on a
pris c'est que l'état joue un rôle
important il faut que continuer à jouer
mais ça me paraît pas nécessaire
d'envisager des nationalisations du show
des gens quand on est retourné à l'état
normal en état d'urgence bien sûr l'état
de la jeune rôle un rôle plus important
bien merci pour vos lumières ce soir à
levier d'un phare à washington merci